[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans le naufrage des civilisations un
des derniers livres que vous avez écrit
paru chez Grasset vous dites contempler
le monde arabe avec angoisse est-ce que
cette angoisse c'est celle aussi qui
vous tient quand vous contempler
l'Afrique
dans l'ensemble oui se dirait qu'il y a
de différence entre les pays il y a des
pays qui arrivent à inventer une place
dans le monde d'aujourd'hui mais dans
l'ensemble c'est inquiétant d'ailleurs
pas seulement pour le monde arabe et
pour l'Afrique mais je dirais pour le
monde entier globalement bien sûr alors
le naufrage des civilisations est-ce que
on peut considérer que l'Afrique c'est
une civilisation il y a plusieurs
civilisations en Afrique non toujours
difficile de parler d'une civilisation
est-ce que il y a une civilisation
occidentale oui et non il y a une
civilisation occidentale et en même
temps il y a des des nuances des
différences d'un pays à l'autre d'un
continent à l'autre mais je pense que
ces termes aide à approcher un peu de la
réalité à
essayer de décoder un peu la réalité
l'Afrique est extrêmement extrêmement
diverses on a besoin quand on regarde de
l'extérieur de trouver des points
communs de généraliser un peu on ne peut
pas regarder dans le détail sur chaque
élément culturel mais c'est vrai qu'on
peut parler de la réalité africaine mais
il faut savoir qu'on a que c'est une
approximation bien sûr alors vous êtes
né au Liban
Franco libanais mais vous avez passé une
grande partie de votre jeunesse aussi en
Égypte vous avez été directeur de la
rédaction de jeunes Afrique le grand
hebdomadaire panafricain francophone et
puis vous êtes l'auteur d'un livre
absolument admirable qui s'appelle Léon
l'Africain qui est en fait la vie
romancée d'un homme qui s'appelait
Hassan El Ouazan qui est donc dit Léon
l'Africain il a écrit ce qu'on appelle
description de l'Afrique et une
description très minutieuse de ce
continent africain et ce livre là a
inspiré énormément tous les explorateurs
du XIXe et du 20e siècle pourquoi
l'Afrique elle fascine et elle a fasciné
autant
ce livre n'a pas uniquement fasciné
des gens comme vous et moi il y a un
personnage qui est
on le sait pas beaucoup qui a été
fasciné par la traduction anglaise de ce
livre c'est Shakespeare il y a des
spécialistes de Shakespeare qui
considèrent que le personnage doté l'eau
lui a été inspiré par le récit de Léon
l'Africain qu'il avait lu dans une
traduction qui est sortie au début de de
du 17e siècle peut être l'an 1600 et on
sait qu'il l'avait lu et qu'il avait
noté
qu'il y avait une forme de jalousie sur
laquelle insiste beaucoup Léon
l'Africain dans certaines de celui-ci et
il a attribué à ôtello donc il y a des
des influences remarquables et hôteliers
absolument alors votre parcours c'est un
parcours de migration de nomadisme
l'Afrique c'est le nomadisme par
définition non je me suis passionné très
tôt pour l'Afrique peut-être à l'origine
parce que ma petite enfance s'est passée
en partie en Egypte qui était le pays de
ma mère de la famille de ma mère
mais c'est vrai que mes premières
passions
quand j'ai commencé à observer le monde
était lié à l'Afrique et mes premières
lectures aussi étaient liées à l'Afrique
une de mes premières indignations
quand je j'ai eu je sais pas 17 18 ans
et que je voulais changer le monde
était lié à la bataille j'étais
tellement indigné que l'on puisse parler
de de séparation des races c'était
c'était une chose qui me paraissait
totalement insupportable révoltante et
je dirais que c'était ma première
ma première révolte d'adolescents et dès
que j'ai commencé à travailler comme
journaliste et voulu aller en Afrique
vous avez d'abord travaillé pour des
quotidiens libanais absolument je
commençais à travailler dans un
quotidien libanais en 71 et un de mes
premiers grands voyages et je dirais une
de mes premières passions c'était
l'Afrique orientale l'Éthiopie notamment
et quand il a eu le début de la
Révolution éthiopienne
je me suis pris de passion pour ce pays
et je commençais à y aller
c'est l'acier alors oui j'étais
probablement un dérable journaliste
étrangers avoir
assisté sur place à la chute de la CRS
le 12 septembre 74 j'étais là et je me
souviens encore d'amis Ethiopien qui
m'ont emmené avec eux parce qu'il
manifestaient dans les rues et donc j'ai
manifesté avec eux pour célébrer la fin
de la monarchie depuis les choses se
sont malheureusement mal passées en tout
cas à la fin de du régime monarchique il
y a eu ce qu'on appelle la déguste rouge
oui il y a eu minguistou il y a eu des
massacres il y a eu la guerre avec eux
mais c'était c'était des événements
fascinants mais sinon parce que
l'Éthiopie c'est un pays de grandes
cultures aussi et de culture chrétienne
les gens ne le savent pas beaucoup ça je
crois que tous ceux qui se passionnent
pour l'Afrique
ont une un faible pour l'Éthiopie parce
que ça a été le pays qui a gardé la
dignité de l'Afrique quand toute
l'Afrique était occupée quand toute
l'Afrique était colonisée
l'Éthiopie est restée indépendante
jusqu'à jusqu'au moment où elle a été
attaquée par monsoline mais mais elle
s'est battue et elle est restée comme un
symbole
ce n'est pas par hasard que que Senghor
parle des éthiopies ce n'est pas par
hasard qui a eu même dans les Antilles
les rastafari qui qui était inspiré par
race Safari qui était le Négus j'ai pris
absolument donc l'Éthiopie a toujours
été dans l'imaginaire de ceux qui qui
aiment l'Afrique elle avait toujours eu
une place à part et le reggae est très
très écouté d'ailleurs il y a un
festival de reggae on Éthiopie tous les
ans qui a beaucoup de succès
expliquez-nous à minimalouf pourquoi
en Afrique de l'Ouest par exemple il y a
énormément de Libanais qui tiennent
d'ailleurs une grande partie du commerce
quelle est l'explication de cela
émigré partout
il se définit parfois le Liban comme une
montagne au bord de la mer la montagne
préserve l'identité
et le bord de mer ouvre vers le reste du
monde les Libanais vivaient sur une
terre aride
souvent sous des régimes pas très
accueillants pas très
encourageant pour le l'épanouissement de
la personne et ils ont toujours eu
tendance à partir avant même le Liban la
première grande migration remonte à près
de 3000 ans quand dis donc à quitté tir
avec beaucoup de ses proches pour aller
fonder Carthage c'est une grande
migration de même type parce que la vie
devenait étroite en quelque sorte dans
son propre pays tout au long de
l'histoire
les Libanais
sont partis c'est vrai qu'ils sont
partis en Afrique mais ils sont partis
en Amérique latine et en Amérique du
Nord en Australie partout ils sont
éparpillés dans dans le monde entier ou
alors en France comme c'est mon cas
aujourd'hui et il y a de la famille
malouf de votre famille en Afrique de
l'Ouest au Sénégal en Côte d'Ivoire
non j'ai rencontré des maloufs en
Algérie en Tunisie des gens de ma
famille qui avait émigré là c'est moins
fréquent mais il y a eu en revanche il y
a beaucoup de gens de ma famille au
Brésil et on en Amérique du Nord Brésil
il y a des défilés alors il y a des
Libanais en Afrique de l'Ouest et en
Afrique de l'Est alors là ce sont des
Indiens qui sont arrivés notamment pour
la construction du chemin de fer c'est
ça
les Indiens sont arrivés
parce que c'était l'Empire britannique
et beaucoup de gens circulaient à
l'intérieur de l'Empire britannique
comme d'ailleurs au sein de l'Empire
français et libanais qui qui était sous
mandat français venait dans d'autres
territoires comme le Sénégal ou la Côte
d'Ivoire bien sûr pour l'Angleterre il y
a eu une très grande présence sur la
côte qui fait face à l'Asie il y a
beaucoup de personnages célèbres qui
sont nés dans cette région du monde vont
devenir en Angleterre je citerai les
chicsonac par exemple dans la famille
vient de là le Premier ministre ou alors
Freddie Mercury
qui est né à Zanzibar et et qui dans la
famille vient vient également de là elle
chante pour deux gars et on peut aussi
citer d'une certaine façon alors il est
Gandhi qui est né en Afrique du Sud ce
que les gens ne savent pas beaucoup
Gandhi a fait une partie de sa carrière
en Afrique du Sud en se battant contre
c'est son premier combat avant même son
combat contre la colonisation
britannique en Inde il s'est battu
contre la bataille alors aujourd'hui un
des grands
des grands fléaux du 21e siècle c'est
celui de l'immigration contrainte
souvent obligée par la misère par le
réchauffement climatique par les guerres
et beaucoup d'Africains qui migrent vers
ce qu'il pense être l'Eldorado c'est une
tragédie ça du continent africain cette
obligation de quitter leur continent
nous sommes dans un monde où
il n'y a plus de frontières aux images
on chacun
sait comment les choses se passent
ailleurs
et les gens ont envie de d'aller là où
ils peuvent vivre mieux et je dirais que
il y a une paradoxe à notre époque c'est
que il est beaucoup plus difficile de
voyager des migrés du temps de mes
grands-parents on descendait on prenait
le bateau et on allait on n'avait pas
besoin de passeport on n'avait pas
besoin de visa on allait là où on
voulait là qui se retrouvait à Buenos
Aires ou à New York aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans un monde qui est
prétendument ouvert mais qui est
extrêmement réglementé extrêmement
fermée et
je comprends les gens qui qui ont envie
d'aller ailleurs rien n'oblige quelqu'un
à rester à l'endroit où il est né et à
vivre une vie misérable et en même temps
on ne peut pas ne pas comprendre aussi
ceux qui vivent dans un pays qui vont
arriver des gens de l'extérieur et qui
ont envie de préserver leur mode de vie
leur
malheureusement il n'y a pas de solution
malheureusement ah bon nous sommes dans
un vous êtes pessimiste à ce point là
alors il n'y a pas de solution parce que
on ne va pas
développer le monde entier au même
niveau il y aura toujours des
différences de développement du régions
à l'autre et à moins de fermer toutes
les portes les gens vont essayer d'aller
là où il pourrait vivre mieux ce n'est
pas par hasard que dans le monde entier
il y a une montée des mouvements
identitaires des mouvements parfois
misophobes qui qui ne veulent pas voir
arriver les autres
je mens la menthe vous vous en la monter
peut-être mais je ne pense pas qui est
de solution il n'y a pas de structure
réalité avec laquelle nous vivons nos
enfants et notre petit enfant vivront
avec cette réalité aussi d'un monde
qui est difficile à gérer et
l'assimilation l'intégration ce sont des
notions qui sont impossibles être
concrétisés ce sont des notions qui
fonctionnent
avec le petit nombre qui fonctionne
beaucoup moins avec la multitude vous
pouvez assimiler des gens qui arrivent
par petites doses surtout si vous
partagez certains nombres de de
d'appartenance commune
quand
on dépasse un certain seuil c'est
devient beaucoup plus difficile le
départ de beaucoup d'Africains vers
l'Europe c'est souvent le départ de de
gens qui appartiennent pas aux classes
les plus pauvres ou plus modestes c'est
un une des tragédie de l'Afrique de voir
ces élites justement c'est celle qu'on
est moyen de partir et c'est ça qui est
terrible aussi pour la vous avez envie
de ces cadres en fait vous avez
entièrement raison mais c'est vrai
partout dans le monde quand on voit
arriver des gens en hayon on a
l'impression que c'est la misère du
monde c'est la misère du monde
sont des gens qui ont encore la capacité
de partir qui ont un esprit d'initiative
qui ont la volonté de chercher une vie
meilleure et effectivement vous avez
parfaitement raison de le dire ce qui
partent sont ceux qui théoriquement
pourraient développer leur pays mais on
peut pas leur imposer de développer leur
pays c'est malheureusement
j'en sais quelque chose il y a des
moments où on est obligé de partir parce
que on ne peut pas résoudre les
problèmes de son pays on peut pas
arrêter une guerre on peut pas arrêter
une guerre civile on peut pas développer
un pays en une génération et donc on est
obligé de faire un choix pour soi-même
pour sa famille et ce choix est souvent
celui de Patty alors aujourd'hui
l'Afrique compte un milliard 300
millions d'individus en 2050 c'est à
dire dans un peu plus de 25 ans
seulement elle en comptera le double
comment on fait
cercle territoire africain il y a
beaucoup de zones qui sont sous peuplées
si je puis dire mais le problème c'est
la concentration dans les villes c'est
l'exode rural et qui fait qu'il y a la
création de métropole qui sont j'ai
envie de dire des nids à misère pour
souvent non je vais vous décevoir mais
je ne veux pas vous mentir je ne pense
pas qu'il y a une solution il y a pas de
solution ni dans le cadre africain il
n'y a rien je pense que c'est ce sont
des réalités avec le mot avec lesquels
le monde
devrait se débrouiller mais mais il n'y
a pas de solution simple je ne vois pas
de solution en tout cas pour moi
la chute de Kadhafi a quand même
déstabilisé toute l'Afrique j'ai envie
de dire toute l'Afrique de l'Ouest vous
êtes d'accord pour dire ça et que cette
déstabilisation et bien aujourd'hui a
des conséquences importantes
souvent aujourd'hui en Occident on a
l'impression qu'on a fait une
erreur en renversant que d'affi je ne le
pense pas vous le pensez pas pour moi la
faute
n'est pas de l'avoir renversée la faute
c'est de d'avoir d'être intervenu
ponctuellement et d'être aussitôt de
cette aussitôt désintéressée de la
situation et je dirais que c'est vrai
partout c'est vrai en Irak c'est
vraiment un Afghanistan c'est partout le
cas quand on s'engage quelque part il
faut
suivre l'engagement il faut continuer il
faut rebâtir quelque chose à la place si
on intervient ponctuellement qu'on
perturbe une situation puis qu'on se
retire en disant ça y est le travail est
fait ça c'est très grave pour tenir la
promesse d'un monde meilleur on aurait
dû et on aurait pu à mon avis
en Libye avoir une autre une autre
attitude le pays n'était pas encore
aussi anarchique qu'il est aujourd'hui
où aurait pu intervenir utiliser
l'argent
que ce pays avait pour le développement
la communauté internationale est
incapable de gérer des situations
pareilles il n'est pas un pays qui soit
capable de gérer on a vu les échecs et
de de des États-Unis et des de l'Europe
et de tout le monde et on se retrouve
dans des situations comme celle de la
Libye actuelle mais ce qu'il fallait à
un moment donné
intervenir et éviter un massacre je
pense que
en me remettant dans l'état d'esprit qui
avait à l'époque oui il fallait il
fallait intervenir mais il fallait
intervenir en engageant tous les pays en
ayant une politique sur le long terme et
pas d'une manière ponctuelle alors tout
à l'heure vous avez parlé de l'Afrique
du Sud c'est assez intéressant parce que
nous autres francophones on parle moins
de l'Afrique du Sud que les anglophones
évidemment
l'Afrique du Sud elle vous fascine vous
avez une grande admiration pour Nelson
Mandela je considère qu'il est un modèle
et que malheureusement ce modèle n'a pas
été suivi dans beaucoup d'autres pays
une des choses qui me fascine c'est qui
s'est battu avec beaucoup de courage
beaucoup d'abnégation beaucoup de
souffrance et le jour où il a gagné il a
dit maintenant on passe à autre chose la
bataille est finie on va construire et
on va construire même avec ce qu'on
vient de combattre il est allé prendre
le thé chez la veuve de l'homme qu'il
avait jeté en prison en lui disant ne
partez pas ce pays est à nous tous nous
devons le construire
cet exemple de générosité me paraît
extraordinaire et ce n'est pas
simplement la générosité générosité
intelligente parce que c'est comme cela
qu'on préserve l'avenir non pas en
chassant ce qu'on vient de combattre et
après on souffrant pendant des
générations parce qu'ils sont partis il
faut essayer d'utiliser toutes les
compétences même celles des gens combien
de combattre et alors vous vous avez
avant même la fin de la partail vous
avez reçu au libertabo
alors que vous étiez au Liban comme je
vous le voulez
par ce combat c'était mon premier mon
premier enthousiasme ma première
indignation et il se fait que Oliver
Tambo qui était le président de l'ANC
parce que Mandela était en prison donc
c'est lui qui le remplaçait en quelque
sorte à l'extérieur et c'est lui qui
voyager à travers le monde pour
pour parler de de leur combat il est
passé par la route Beyrouth
effectivement de la version très heureux
de de l'invité de et de parler avec lui
afin de l'écouter surtout parce que
c'était intéressant une figure
merveilleuse un homme lui aussi moins
connu que Mandela mais un homme qui a
passé sa vie à se battre pour la même
cause alors amine malouf moi vous me
faites penser à un autre une autre
figure très importante de l'Afrique qui
s'appelle Léopold Sédar Senghor il y a
beaucoup de similitudes entre vous deux
d'abord parce que
vous êtes académicien vous êtes
romancier tous les deux lui était poète
vous avez dû écrire des poèmes
d'ailleurs mais vous êtes surtout connu
pour vos romans et vos essais
vous êtes francophone et vous êtes des
ardents défenseur de la Francophonie et
puis vous êtes des passeurs de je dirais
entre les continents entre les
civilisations entre les cultures des
passeurs de culture en fait vous vous
acceptez que je dis ça debout c'est tout
à fait vrai j'aimais beaucoup j'aimais
beaucoup singore
quand ils étaient encore président à
Dakar
18 ans
merveilleux et
c'était un homme de d'ouverture c'était
ce que je ne suis pas un homme politique
très habile et donc c'était à la fois un
homme de culture et un des pères de de
la Fenix moderne il avait une phrase que
j'aimais beaucoup qu'il répétait il
disait je suis un homme honnête ce qui
n'exclut pas labilité je trouve ça
remarquable parce que on attend des gens
honnêtes et qu'ils soient naïfs lui
n'était pas naïf il était habile et
c'est ça qui lui a permis de faire
avancer son pays et d'ailleurs
jusqu'à aujourd'hui je lui attribue pas
tout le tout tout
les bienfaits que de de ce qui s'est
passé au
Sénégal mais c'est vrai que le Sénégal
a connu une voix un peu différente des
autres plus stable qualité de démocratie
un peu meilleur que d'autres une
dimension culturelle
beaucoup mieux que d'autres pays
d'Afrique est d'ailleurs et donc je
trouve que son influence a été bénéfique
certainement alors il a cette autre
phrase est quand vous écoute et quand
vous parlez de votre passion pour
l'Afrique il a cette phrase aussi la
fierté d'être différent n'empêche pas le
bonheur d'être ensemble vous partagez
cette phrase oui et je pense que
sa vision de l'appartenance l'idée de
dire je suis africain et en même temps
je suis je suis français je je me sens
extrêmement proche de la France je n'ai
pas besoin de choisir entre le Sénégal
et la France c'est une vision que pour
ma part je partage entièrement le
naufrage de civilisation vous dites je
suis et libanais et français je je pense
que on a le droit et même le devoir
d'assumer toutes ces appartenances et de
réunir ses appartements c'est d'être un
une passerelle entre les différentes
appartenances
dont on a hérité dites-moi quelle est
votre auteur de littérature africaine
préférée
j'ai envie de vous parler d'un homme qui
est peu connu mais qui a joué un rôle
important dans ma vie oui
c'était en 1974
je me trouvais un Nairobi oui et
l'hôpital du Kenya capitale du Canada à
l'époque on n'avait pas les moyens
d'information que l'on a aujourd'hui
c'était presque à 50 ans quasiment et je
voulais consulter la presse j'étais allé
au British Canson où il y avait toute la
presse
internationale pour pouvoir
ce qui se passait dans le monde
et je rencontre quelqu'un qui qui
travaille là
et
je parle avec lui il avait à peu près
mon âge on sympathise beaucoup et
on va prendre
une bière on boit beaucoup de bière au
Kenya voilà dans un endroit qui
s'appelait de Fruit of the Loom
je me souviens encore de l'endroit et je
lui dis mais
qu'est-ce que tu as fait comme formation
etc il me dit moi je travaille là parce
que c'est un peu alimentaire mais moi je
suis romancier
un livre qui venait de recevoir le
principal prix littéraire du pays qui
était le prix Kenya c'est la première
personne que j'ai rencontré et qui m'a
dit je suis romancier et je me suis dit
tiens on peut on peut avoir comme métier
et il s'appelait en réalité David mungi
et signé mes jambes il a il a fait une
longue carrière
il a été traduit dans beaucoup de
langues
on s'est envoyé quelques messages depuis
on s'est jamais rencontré mais si par
hasard il regardait cette émission je le
salue très chaleureusement et
amicalement merci Amin Maalouf merci
beaucoup